today on the matt walsh show joe biden
made it a day one priority to ensure
that boys and girls
use the same bathroom and he made good
on that promise that was his priority
also five headlines including
bad speeches and bad poetry at the
inauguration plus a 100 day
mask mandate goes into effect and a
professional video game player suffers a
career ending injury very sad story
there and in our daily cancellation
i will cancel the proposed patriot party
before it even has a chance to exist all
of that and much more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
first let's talk about expressvpn you
know i've been talking about expressvpn
on my show for a long time for months
now so why haven't you gotten a vpn yet
why haven't you done it explain that to
me explain it right now
actually explain it later because i got
to tell you more about this ladies and
gentlemen i'll tell you this there has
never been a more important time
to protect your digital rights that's
why i and thousands of my patriotic
listeners choose to secure
our online data by using expressvpn did
you believe that a vpn
isn't for you because you can use the
internet just fine without one you know
that's what a lot of people think
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every site
you're visiting that's the problem
and if you're confused about how it
works expressvpn is an
app for computers and smartphones that
encrypts your network data and reroutes
it through a secure server that's the
basics there that means you can use the
internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked and that way you're getting the
privacy that you have a right to and
that you deserve when you're online
do you think that vpns are complex and
only for tech tech experts that was uh
one of one of the things my worries
going into this is that i i thought well
this sounds complicated but take it from
me it's not that complicated at all with
expressvpn you launch the app and tap
just one button to protect yourself and
that's it
i mean it really is that simple i trust
expressvpn to protect my online data
because they're rated number one by cnet
and wired and they stand for my values
so now is the time for you to take a
stand
and to protect yourself uh this is just
it's you're doing yourself a favor by
doing this take back your privacy
expressvpn.com
walsh and get three extra months free on
a one year package again that's
expressvpn.comwalshexp res
svpn.com walsh to get three extra months
visit expressvpn.com
walsh right now joe biden who for the
first 65 or 70 years of his life
much of it spent in public office show
no interest
in trans issues never hinted in a belief
that biological males can be women if
they feel like it
has now become after just one day in
office the most radically pro-trans
president
ever in history this admittedly is not a
difficult feat after all
almost nobody on earth believed that
women have penises until about
seven years ago and that's when millions
of leftists decided nearly all at once
that everything we know about biological
science is somehow false
well they've yet to explain how it's
false or why they came to believe it to
be false but uh we're supposed to just
accept it anyway
at any rate now we have biden the 78
year old man governing much like a 19
year old college student who just took
her first gender studies class might
and his first act to this end happened
before he took office actually he named
rachel levine who's the current health
secretary of pennsylvania
as his assistant health and human
services secretary
the only reason he did this is that
rachel levine is a quote trans woman i.e
a male who believes himself to be a
woman
and this is what makes the pick historic
we're told
yet what really makes it historic is
that levine is the first
assistant health and human services
secretary to be appointed to the
position
despite arguably being partly
responsible for the deaths of thousands
of people
maybe i should check my facts on that
claim actually it's possible that
other democratic administrations have
appointed planned parenthood officials
to that role in which case levine would
not be the first
um so i'm not quite sure about that
either way the fact is that levine as
health
as health secretary pennsylvania was
presiding when the state adopted a
policy of admitting coveted patients to
nursing homes
since then 10 000 people have died in
nursing homes and care facilities just
in that state alone
we should note that newsweek did a fact
check
a quote fact check big air quotes around
that on the claim that
levine is responsible for the deaths of
thousands of elderly in the state
shockingly they rated the claim false
they said it's not true here's what
newsweek said
although levine serves as the
pennsylvania secretary of health of
health and was active
in that position when the state's health
department issued the guidance to
nursing home facilities saying they can
accept patients from hospitals and
patients
and patients who formerly had cova 19
that does not prove she placed
coronavirus positive patients
in nursing homes or contributed to
thousands of elderly deaths in the state
okay so this policy was in place levine
was the health secretary
but there's no way to connect these dots
no way to blame him for it
who knows who can say and the thing is
even if you put the deaths of thousands
of elderly aside
which you certainly can't but even if
you did still you're left with the fact
that pennsylvania's coveted death rate
is on the higher end of the spectrum
among states
deaths in pennsylvania are at about 152
per 100 000 people by comparison
deaths in florida are at 114 per 100
000. and the media tells us that florida
has been a disaster zone
right ron desantis doing a horrible job
they tell us
well that's true what does that say
about pennsylvania
so even after arbitrarily absolving
levine of all the guilt for the
murderous health policies in the state
where he was health secretary you still
have no reason
on the merits to promote him
but of course on the merits is the whole
rub here this is this is not a promotion
based on the merits this is a promotion
based on the identity
or in this case the identity confusion
speaking of confusion joe biden on his
first day in office
issued a flurry of executive orders he
essentially set out to overturn
trump's entire tenure in one day all
through executive fiat
and he basically did of course it goes
without saying that there wasn't any
hand-wringing from the media about this
violation of norms or the fascist
dictatorial takeover blah blah et cetera
quite the opposite
they celebrated it obviously one of
biden's executive orders is aimed at
quote preventing and combating
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity or sexual orientation
and here's what it says in part by the
authority vested in me as president of
by the constitution and the laws of the
united states of america it is hereby
ordered as follows
every person should be treated with
respect and dignity and should be able
to live without fear no matter
who they are or whom they love children
should be able to learn without worrying
about whether they will be
denied access to the restroom the locker
room or school sports
then it goes on to a great extent from
there but the problem here we just stop
it right there because the problem is
number one
no child is being denied access to the
restroom locker room or school sports
this is not happening this was never
happening
boys are perfectly free to use the boys
room
and play on boy sports there's no denial
here
trans students also are not being denied
anything where is that where was that
happening
well trans students aren't allowed to
use the bathroom really where
the question is whether a boy who says
he's trans should have access to
literally any restroom he wants
or any sports team he wants even if it
means infringing on the rights of real
girls
the answer to that question from any
sane person any morally decent person is
obviously no
we don't have to think about it it's
just a matter of common sense
there's not a lot of reflection required
if you ask a normal sane
morally decent person oh what do you
think do you think um
you think 14 year old girls in in school
should be forced to share a restroom
with a boy who says he's gender confused
a normal sane person says of course not
obviously not
there's there's no reason to allow that
and every reason not to but biden has no
common sense or sense of any other kind
at this point and he is not morally
decent either despite the way he's
branded
the second problem is that the
constitution in no way
vests in the president the authority to
decide which sports team a kid can play
on
or which locker rooms they can use this
is
by no means by no reasonable
interpretation and constitutional power
granted to the president
in fact no human anywhere has the
legitimate moral or legal authority
to demand that girls share the locker
room with boys
nobody does but this is the authority
biden has claimed for himself and it's
so important to him personally that
girls be forced to disrobe in front of
boys
that he made it a day one priority
as the media has been telling us and
maybe i'm sure they'll stop telling us
now
people are dying every day in a pandemic
and biden is focused on ensuring that
little girls have no privacy in the
bathroom that's what he's worried about
this is not the action of a decent man
but of a deranged amoral pervert
or else of a hapless gutless coward
enacting somebody else's agenda because
he lacks the spine or the brain power
to do the right thing my guess is that
it's a little bit of both
we're told that you know biden's
administration is a return to normalcy
in some ways it is
because degeneracy and the victimization
of children
is normal in our culture that's what
biden promised
normalcy is what he's delivering with a
lot more where this came from
on the way i'm sure let's get now to our
five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines you
know one thing that is i think that's
just killing a lot of people uh even
people that otherwise they've got they
got their finances in order and they've
got everything
figured out but they've got higher
balances on their credit cards
than they should they got a higher
interest rate and they're you're just
you're just losing money every second
when you've got a situation like that if
you're thinking about the high interest
rate credit cards that you used over the
holidays
when it comes to refinancing your credit
cards you've got options
but only lightstream was ranked number
one by jd power for customer
satisfaction
with personal loans um lightstream's
credit card consolidation loans start at
just
5.95 apr with auto pay and excellent
credit
you could save thousands in interest
this is just one of those things
that you could do for yourself um and
it's it's
it's smart you know this is you're doing
yourself a favor
by um by using lightstream because
there's no reason to have these
high interest rates you got a high
balance on the card and you're you're
losing
you're losing money you're basically
setting money on fire stop doing that
stop setting money on fire
you can even get your money as soon as
the day you apply um
and here's what you got to do apply
today for a credit card consolidation
loan for the company
jd power rank number one for customer
satisfaction and personal loans
plus get an additional interest rate
discount at lightstream.com
walsh that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m-com
walsh subject to credit approval range
rates from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include 0.5
autopay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
walsh for more information
all right you know i woke up this
morning at 6 a.m uh i
went outside at 6am and my my boys
were awake running through the house at
6 a.m
playing cowboys and indians um and which
i already know of course cultural
appropriation
all of that i i talked to them about
that but um but the point is that
my my youngest son for the four-year-old
he uh
his indian headdress was his his pants
that he had taken off and put on his
head
and so he's running pantless through the
house at six a.m
the pants on his head playing indian
indians
and i i just thought as i saw this you
know it's it's
if i could have even a fraction of the
energy that i had as a kid kids are
full of so much energy if we could just
maintain even a fraction of that as
adults
think of all the things we could
accomplish
and this is also why by the way uh it's
important to have kids young
you know you don't want to wait until
your late 30s or 40s to have kids there
are a lot of reasons for that but this
is one of them
because they demand a lot of energy
you're not going to have all the energy
for them
but i cannot imagine being like 45 and
having
a kid who runs through the house at 6am
with his pants on his head
all right um so number one the
inauguration yesterday was uh was was it
first of all let me say this about the
inauguration and and what's happened
um with this new administration i just
want to acknowledge this
obviously i'm a conservative and i'm a
critic of the new administration but but
when a historic moment occurs i think we
should all acknowledge it
and the truth is that a glass ceiling
was shattered yesterday
when the first man with full-blown
dementia was inaugurated president
this never happened before in history so
that is you know that's uh that is a
glass ceiling shattering moment
and we should acknowledge that uh biden
gave a long speech
for some reason i'll play a quick clip
of it i don't even know why i'm doing
this
but here is a quick little clip of
biden's
inauguration speech here we go history
faith and reason
show the way the way of unity
we can see each other not as adversaries
but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
we can join forces stop the shouting and
lower the temperature
for without unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury no progress
only exhausting outrage
[Music]
you know once again it doesn't really
mean anything
if you wait until you win to say
this if you're only a good
sport when after you win the game
it's the sportsmanship doesn't mean much
so your calls for unity and peace
didn't hear much about that during the
campaign especially when the blm was was
uh he was talking about exhausting
outrage
didn't hear much about it then um and he
talks about
treating people with dignity i i believe
that 100
but we have to keep in mind i'm sorry
that that when when
joe biden or any democrat talks about
treating people with dignity
he is he is ruling a lot of people out
of the people category so that's you got
to read the fine print
any time a democrat says anything
especially when they're talking about
human dignity
read the fine print because there's
little asterisks there and you gotta
look down at the fine print
and you'll see there that people
that does not include babies who are
still in the womb
so that that that excludes millions of
people from the people categories we're
not treating them with dignity
unless i don't know dismembering a
person and throwing them into a dumpster
like abortion clinics do to millions of
children
every year is that are we counting that
as dignity
so maybe that's where the fine print is
treating someone with dignity
could include dismembering them and
throwing them in a dumpster
and is it are we treating our our
daughters with dignity
when they are when they are begging us
and saying no please don't let boys into
the
bathroom with me i want my privacy i i
feel unsafe with the boys here
and we say to them shut up and deal with
it is that treating them with dignity i
don't know
chris wallace uh over at fox he listened
to this inauguration speech
and he said it was the best one he's
ever heard let's let's listen to that
we must end this uncivil war and the
way we can do it is if we show each
other a little tolerance and humility
martha i thought it was a great speech
i've been listening to these inaugural
addresses
since 1961 john f kennedy asked not
i thought this was the best inaugural
address i ever heard
best he's ever heard and it was okay it
was
real leaving aside all the hypocrisy and
everything else
it was just sort of fine and that's what
you get
so you get from most political speeches
i i i have as
i've said many times in the past i've
actually nev i don't think i've ever
heard a speech from a politician
um in my life i mean unless we're going
back through history i'm talking about a
current politician a speech that i've
listened to live of a current politician
i've never heard one that that
that really was great the
the the best they could be is great by
the standards of politicians
i've never heard one that was really
memorable
what was the last speech from a
politician that
you heard and years later you know there
are lines from that speech that you
still recall and still remember
i'm not sure it's ever happened i mean
the one example of that may be of a
truly
like what is the we think of truly
memorable
uh political speeches in our lifetime
and to be truly memorable you actually
have to remember certain lines from it
without going back to google that's what
memorable means right so has there been
even one
the only one that comes to mind for me
maybe would be george bush
his impromptu speech that he gave
standing on top of the rubble of the
tower into the megaphone
you know when he said i i hear you and
soon the people who knock down these
towers they're gonna hear all of us
that's a line i remember that might be
the only memorable political speech you
could say whatever else you want about
george bush
plenty of criticisms you could lob at
him but at least that was a good speech
and a good moment okay
um also we should also mention that we
didn't play the clip but in fairness
we should also mention that joe biden
did denounce white supremacy and he got
a lot of credit from that from the media
too he denounced white supremacy in his
inaugural
address so he is keeping up the
tradition now that the new tradition
um that says that presidents have to
ritualistically denounce
white supremacy every 45 minutes so he's
going to keep that going which is great
um but you know black supremacy for
example that we get from from black
lives matter we're not going to get any
denunciations of that
because without saying now there was a
another moment from the inauguration
that a lot of people talked about so it
was very beautiful
a poem delivered by amanda gorman this
is kind of a
slam poetry and everyone no i admit i'm
a philistine okay i'm a classless
philistine dropped at a community
college what do i know
but i listen to this poem i i i didn't
quite get it i understand
what i get what she's trying to say i
didn't see the beauty and the art in it
personally
but you you tell me what you think let's
listen and yes we are
far from polished far from pristine but
that doesn't mean we are
striving to form a union that is perfect
we are striving to forge our union
with purpose to compose a country
committed
to all cultures colors characters
and conditions of man and so we lift our
gazes not to what stands
between us but what stands before us
we close the divide because we know to
put our future first
we must first put our differences aside
we
lay down our arms so we can reach out
our arms to one
another we seek harm to none and harmony
for all let the globe if nothing else
say this is true
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we try
that we'll forever be
tied together victorious not because we
will never again
know defeat but because we will never
again so division
is that even poetry i hear that she's
saying it with a certain
rhythm i guess but i don't i think
poetry has to have metaphor or beauty
i just i don't i don't see it i'm sorry
i don't hear it
it's not just her but modern here's the
thing modern
poetry to me much of it uh especially
this kind of slam poetry style
it sound it always sounds to me like a
glorified blog post
you can just imagine this written in
someone's blog post
uh it's but you you say it with a
certain rhythm and now all of a sudden
it's poetry
i i don't mean to be a hater but
i'm sorry what can i say um number two
from
the independent says mr biden kicked off
his presidency by issuing his much
anticipated 100 day mask
challenge to the country pairing it with
an executive order to
mandate mask wearing in all federal
buildings and during interstate travel
remember federal buildings we'll get to
that in a second uh
mr biden explained to reporters it's
it's requiring as i said along where i
have authority mandating masks be worn
social distancing be kept on federal
property
um president is also reorganizing the
way the white house's institutional
approach to the quota virus pandemic
bringing back an obama era position
within the administration entitled the
directorate for global health security
and biodefense
and he brought in some more people for
that for that position as well
um first of all i'll say
you know to president biden i hear your
challenge 100 days of wearing the mask
i hear that i hear you i hear what
you're saying i'm going to ignore it
um i'm not gonna do that i'm just gonna
continue along like i was before
i understand your opinion about whether
i should wear a mask i understand what
your opinion is about what i should have
on my face
it just doesn't mean anything to me i
don't care
um i don't i don't care about your
opinion as the president about what i'm
wearing on my face
and i don't recognize your authority to
tell me so i'm going to continue right
along
doing what i was doing before which is
most of the time not really wearing the
mask to be honest with you
and why a hundred days we still haven't
been told that why 100 days why not 90
went out 150
well not 200. and we already know if we
look at 15 days to slow the spread that
was 9 months well 100 days
do the math for that that turns into i
don't know years and years and years of
wearing the mask
which we are also being told by the
media now
uh we're starting to see the articles
come out in the headlines that
hey even after you get vaccinated you
probably still should wear the mask
it's just a good it's a it's a so it's a
good healthy thing to do why not wear it
it's that's that you know
no skin off your nose that you're just
covering your nose what's the big deal
it's extra skin on your nose in a
certain way but mr biden
um as he's called here he was he
he says where the the mask in federal
buildings
well later on that day he was in a
federal building the lincoln memorial
and let's take a look here and see if
he's wearing a mask let's watch
hello all the participants tonight event
it's humbling to stand here in this
place in front of these sacred words
humbling out of respect to president
lincoln and the office
we now share and humbling because of you
the american people
as i said earlier today we've learned
again that democracy is precious
he's not wearing the mask his
that's the twist ending there no mask
after he just told us we have to wear it
except for him
we've learned that lesson by now right
this is from cbs sports it says the nfl
announced tuesday it's official eight
person officiating crew for
super bowl for the upcoming super bowl
in doing so
it um it marked a historic achievement
for sarah thomas six years after
becoming the first full-time female
official in league history she's set to
become
the first woman to officiate a super
bowl teaming up with 20-year
your 21-year veteran carl chafers on
this year's championship cruise so this
is uh
another big deal historic we're gonna
have our first
female uh first woman officiating the
super bowl
i don't know why i picked this story
because there's nothing i can say about
it that that won't get me in trouble
so maybe i'll just move on but the only
thing i'll say is
you know i mean no offense when i say
this but i guess you may as well have
women officiating
nfl games at this point because anytime
there's a big hit
already the refs are like they're like
my like my wife hey gentle
gentle boys be nice no hitting
honey the boys are fighting again can
you come in here and talk to them
that's already what the refs do so i
guess you might as well
as we're bringing women for more of that
sort of uh authentic maternal
side number four um
the first white house press conference
under the new administration happened
yesterday
there was one good question during the
whole press conference
and it's a very good question in fact
i'm very happy it was asked i'm a little
surprised
that because this is a question from a
reporter for ewtn i'm a little surprised
they got called on
but they made use of their time here it
is go ahead all the way in the back
yeah hi uh congratulations on your new
position uh owen jensen with ewtn global
catholic network
two big concerns for pro-life americans
the hyde amendment
which of course who keeps tax
payer dollars as you know from paying
for abortions medicaid abortions
and the mexico city policy which under
the previous administration
expanded to keep tax dollars from
overseas paying for abortions
so what our president what does
president biden planning on doing in
those two items right now
uh well i think we'll have more to say
on the mexico city policy in the coming
days
um but i will just take the opportunity
to
remind all of you that he is a devout
catholic and somebody who
attends church regularly uh he started
his day attending church with his family
this morning
um but i don't have anything more
okay that was the strangest non-sequitur
what does that have to do with anything
you were asked about his
what he's going to do mexico city policy
height amendment
very specific policy questions that's a
good question from from that reporter
very from ewtn and is the the answer is
well he went to chur he went to church
this morning that was the answer to the
question of are you going to force
federal funding of abortion
they went to church now
if if that answer means anything if it's
indicating anything
um it should be indicating that well of
course not of course he's not going to
force federal funding of abortion or
force us to pay for abortions overseas
or anything like that
that's that's that's what it should mean
and i would appreciate it if that's what
it meant
you know if the question was is the
president going to force federal funding
of abortion
well what do you mean he goes to church
of course not what do you expect he's a
christian he's a real christian
but i'm i i suspect that's not the
implication of that answer
the implication is uh yeah he's gonna
he's radically pro-abortion we already
know that
he wants federal funding he wants to
increase funding of planned parenthood
and everything else
uh but you you can't criticize criticize
him for that
as a conservative christian because he's
a christian too
and so because a christian who's in a
position of power
supports this position that means
christians can support it that means
it's a valid position for christians to
hold
that's the logic and it is deranged
logic
it's not logic at all because that's
absolutely not true
and as a catholic you know
if you are a catholic and you
categorically reject
and deny the moral authority of the
catholic church
then you're not a catholic and so that's
how i can say that's how i can
that's how i i can sit here and actually
say
joe biden is not a catholic he says he's
a catholic he's lying he's not one
that is a lie and yes i can say that
because no i don't i'm not peering
inside his soul i'm not reading his mind
i don't need to
i'm listening to what he says
and i also know that being a catholic
means something
and one of the things that it means at a
minimum is that you accept the moral
authority of the church
if you don't you don't have to right
living in america you don't have to
accept the
moral authority of the church um and if
you don't then okay you're not a
catholic
you can be anything else
but if you are catholic that's what it
means joe biden categorically denies the
moral authority of the church
because the church has always been very
clear on this
for 2 000 years in fact it's been very
clear about killing babies
it is gravely immoral it is gravely
immoral mortally sinful to do
gravely immoral mortally sinful to
support the fund to promote
and you as a catholic you cannot say
i disagree and still remain a catholic
right that's that's a logical conclusion
in the same way that um
you know i cannot say i'm
a mormon but i deny that joseph smith
was a prophet
like i i can't say that i can physically
say it
but in saying it i have denounced my
mormonism if i was mormon which i'm not
but
um if you claim to be part of a religion
but you reject the basic tenets of that
religion then you're not part of that
religion
on the other end i can't say uh i'm an
atheist
but i believe in god well then you're
not an atheist
it's not like you're being ruled out of
atheism by some overarching
you know authority of atheism but it's
just that's a lot there's there's a
logical contradiction here
right so there's a logical contradiction
in saying that you're a catholic who
supports abortion
all right number five new york post has
this a 25 year old professional video
game player has been
hang on let's start over again a 25 year
old professional video game player
that's a thing has been forced to log
off for good due to a thumb injury
thomas poporado who goes by the online
moniker zuma
announced he was stepping back from
gaming for the foreseeable future in a
statement on twitter on tuesday
uh breaks my heart to step away from a
game i put my heart and soul into every
single day for eight years he wrote
uh paparazzo who played with the new
york subliners
one of the world's top call of duty
league esports teams
thanked fans for their confidence and
support i don't mean to laugh about this
i'm sorry he
suffered this injury especially because
that's a there's a hell of a gig to have
play video games so there are teams of
people who play video games do they
do people come and watch i'm so
incredibly out of touch this
i'm i'm shocked by all of this i didn't
know any of this existed or was a thing
and i and i'm starting to regret really
all of my life choices
i wish i could go back in time become a
become a gamer
become a professional video game player
that is a that is a hell of a life
but uh paparazzo is i guess hanging up
the video game controls and uh
controllers and you know calling it a
day retiring the jersey
so great career and uh we wish him well
in his future endeavors
there are some problems that we might
face that we we've we've learned or we
think you just have to deal with it and
there's nothing you can do about it
there's no solution one of those is the
problem of thinning hair
80 million men and women in the us
experience thinning hair
yet it's still not openly talked about
which can make going through it feels
scary and stressful
just adds to the problem and it also
means you might not know that there is
something you can do it's called
neutrophil neutrophil is formulated with
potent
botanicals to help your hair grow as
strong as you are and it's physician
formulated to be 100 drug free
neutrophils physician formulated
uh once again and that means that you
know but all but also you don't have to
worry about all the drugs and chemicals
and everything else on top of
thicker stronger hair without lasers or
chemicals neutrophils ingredients may
also help you get a handle on better
sleep
stress response skin nails libido so
there's a lot of stuff you get in this
one little package visit
nutrafall.com and take their hair
wellness quiz for customized product
recommendations that put the power
to grow thicker stronger hair back into
your hands
here's the question does it work well
yes it does in clinical studies
72 of men saw more scalp coverage and 86
of women saw improved hair growth after
six months so whether you're
experiencing thinning or not you deserve
hair as strong as you are neutral fall
can help you achieve your best hair
growth naturally
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafall.com and using promo code walls
to get 20
off your first subscription that is
their best offer available anywhere
plus free shipping on every order get
twenty percent off at nutrafall.com
promo code walsh
their best offer anywhere again twenty
percent off at nutrifault.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com promo code walsh for hair as
strong as you are
if you haven't heard about it yet daily
wire is now in the entertainment game
you probably have
heard us talk about this and for good
reason run hide fight
is uh the movie it's our first movie and
it's getting a great reception from
the audience and from people that are
becoming daily wire members to watch it
um and you can do that too become a
daily wire member today you can watch
the movie
all you got to do is use promo code rhf
to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off um
we've picked run hide fight after
hollywood studio after hollywood studios
turned down the movie because they
thought it was quote distasteful
in fact you can go to rottentomatoes.com
and you can see that it's got like
14 15 uh
fresh rating by rotten tomatoes from
critics whereas the audience loves it so
here's just one example a critic
over at the armchair auteur said while i
found this film considerably less
distasteful than i imagined
that i might going in it's still being
released by some despicable people
and the film's underlying themes are
gross that said more entertaining than
one might assume so that was a negative
review and i take that personally
despicable people how dare you
um but then you look down at the
audience reviews
here's what one person said i do not
care what your politics are or how you
feel about the daily wire if you have a
chance to see this film please do it is
a shame that hollywood said no to this
film
it needs to be made because one it
addresses a subject matter that needs to
be addressed number two
it celebrates the heroes rather than
obsessing over the villains and number
three if embraced correctly it could be
a rally and cry for better schools so
you see that's
that's the dichotomy between audience
versus the critics we're excited to
bring you this we're excited to bring
you many great stories
that hollywood refuses to tell you can
get 25 off when you use promo code rhf
over at dailywire.com go there now but
first let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel something
that doesn't actually exist at the
moment this is a preemptive measure the
cancellation equivalent of a vaccine if
you will
i'm canceling the patriot party as
briefly mentioned on the show yesterday
there are reports that donald trump
wants to start a third party and call it
the patriot party
we haven't heard this from trump himself
frankly i'm skeptical that trump would
actually do that but
uh whether trump does it or not the idea
of a third party has gained traction in
the last couple of days with a
significant number of conservatives just
based on my own interactions
expressing enthusiasm for the idea
but they're wrong it is a terrible idea
whatever you call this third party
whoever starts it whoever's involved
it is an abysmally stupid and
self-destructive plan and i will explain
why
and hear me out okay two reasons
first matter of mathematics i'm not good
at math but i
i could say this at least and as i
always say it's better to
operate in reality rather than fantasy
reality is where i like to live and make
my decisions so in reality
the country is divided right now
ideologically into a roughly 50 50 split
and that's probably being generous to
the right we're at most 50
right at most and again that's the
reality i'm not saying i like it but it
doesn't matter if i like it or if you
like it it is what it is
that means that a right-wing third party
especially
one where trump is involved but even if
he isn't
we'll be pulling from only 50 of the
population
so now it's time for basic math if the
left stays together with
with its 50 percent and the right
takes it's fifty fifty percent and
splits it up
then you tell me how the right ever wins
another election again
ever until the end of time and you
really i mean it's not it's not even
rhetorical someone tell me how this
works
because i don't see it you've got 50 you
need to beat the other 50
and then you subtract from your 50 and
you
win how now
you might say that i'm building my
argument on a false premise this assumes
that a patriot party or whatever other
right-wing third party
we come up with would only siphon votes
from the republicans what if it takes
from democrats too it mobilizes a bunch
of moderates and politically uninvolved
people
well yes that would certainly be a
different situation entirely but that
brings us back to the pesky real world
where there simply is no platform you
could possibly
devise that would be appealing to
disaffected right-wing trump supporters
and significant numbers of democrats and
moderates
that platform doesn't exist
and maybe if this was 150 years ago it
would exist or 200 years ago it would
exist
doesn't now and if the idea is for this
to be
a nationalist party then you certainly
are not going to
uh be getting anyone but your fellow
right wingers to join just look at the
poll numbers you don't have to trust
any one particular poll but look at look
at any poll
any literally any nationalist position
on immigration which i agree with
wholeheartedly by the way
does not enjoy wide approval among
liberals and moderates i wish it did but
it doesn't that's why they're liberals
and moderates
in order to be appealing to all these
groups and thus to have a chance to do
something other than simply guaranteed
democrat victories for the next century
you would have to come up with a
moderate platform but that's exactly the
thing the republican party is already
doing and it's exactly the thing that
probably pisses you off and makes you
want to leave
so you see the problem here there is no
path to victory there's
it doesn't exist i wish it did it
doesn't
now you might say and this is what i've
heard from a lot of people
that the idea really is to teach the
republicans a lesson
stick it to the establishment etc well
okay
are you willing to forfeit the country
and the future
and my children's future to achieve that
goal you want to spit in the eye of the
republican party by giving the left
everything it ever dreamed of that seems
a rather self-destructive path it's a
suicide bombing
and the only person you're blowing up is
yourself
by the way the establishment republican
party this is so important to understand
they would love it if all the pesky
right-wing
agitators left and formed their own
little party
and ensured that they the establishment
remained in office
but never had actual power they would
love that mitch mcconnell
if you hate mitch mcconnell okay he
would love it
if you left and did this it would be the
best thing that ever happened to him
because this is exactly the position
they want to be in they want to be in
office
but not with the burden of real power
and the expectations of real leadership
so in an effort to
poke the establishment in the eye you'd
be giving the establishment what it
wants
namely you gone and the left
and you're also giving the left what it
wants namely
itself in power forever the only person
who wouldn't get what they want
is you so this plan is sounding worse by
the minute
we're not even at the end yet second
point the reason
for starting a third party correct me if
i'm wrong
but the reason would be that the
republican party is run by shills
charlatans and frauds
i agree with that assessment but here's
my question why do you think the patriot
party
wouldn't be run by exactly the same
sorts of people
shills charlatans and frauds we will
always have with us
everywhere we go especially in politics
coming up with a new party and giving it
a new name
is in no way a protection against this
if anything it's a it's a guarantee of
it happening
because you're creating a void that will
be filled
with these kinds of people will be
all you have to do is look at the
political landscape right now as it
currently stands
look at the people who are critics of
the gop establishment
some of them are sincere and honest some
of them are hacks and frauds
just as bad as the people they're
criticizing in some cases
worse look what happened to the tea
party
granted the tea party wasn't its own
political party but even so it began as
a real and sincere movement but quickly
within less than a year
it was overrun by grifters exploiting it
for money power and fame
then it fizzled out and look where it is
now nowhere
and it is really nowhere one of the
things that mobilized the tea party
early on allegedly was
was the budget and spending taxes um
the republican party gave up on that the
republican party for the last four years
has been
spending money hand over fist
what happened to the tea party didn't
care
as if to prove my point i saw this
morning that there is already
a um there's already a patriot party
twitter account now it's not an official
account obviously because the party
doesn't exist but
it has a large following and a growing
following and all the account does is
tweet out stuff like
retweet if you think trump was awesome
smiley face
flag emoji and the account also sells
t-shirts so they send out these tweets
of retweet this
here's a little bumper sticker slogan
retweet and then they have a link to buy
their t-shirts
so here's my point the patreon party
doesn't exist yet
and already there are charlatans using
it successfully
to enrich themselves the patriot party
doesn't exist yet and already
it is essentially just a slightly more
cringy version
of the republican party which is also
what the tea party became
it's what everything becomes in the end
sad to say even the libertarian party is
basically just the republican party but
with weed
i mean they nominated gary johnson in
2016 for god's sake
that's why the third party idea is bad
what then is a better option
well i already made my case yesterday
that reclaiming the culture is going to
have to happen at a much more
fundamental level
you aren't going to solve our problems
politically you won't even you're not
even going to solve our political
problems politically
even if the republican party did
everything that we wanted it to do most
of that stuff can be
undone whenever the democrats get in
power biden has already erased trump's
whole presidency and all of his
achievements almost and he hasn't even
completed his second day in office yet
that's the way it works politics is like
writing your name in the same
in in the sand it's only a matter of
time before the tide comes up and washes
it away
if you want to make a lasting difference
lasting change achieve
lasting victory it happens locally it
happens in the family
essentially conservatives need to have a
bunch of kids and homeschool them that's
my plan
okay that's what i propose have a bunch
of kids homeschool them
um and anything short of that will be
like a band-aid at best but as far as
political band-aids go
given all the issues i've raised um the
better plan
is for the radical right-wing extremist
wing of the party of which i am a proud
member
stay in the party get louder
get more annoying get pushier grow in
number
and take over the positions of power
within i'm not saying this is a
bulletproof plan by any means but it's
better than the third party plan which
is bulletproof only in its certainty of
failure
again the establishment wants you to
leave leaving gives them what they want
so don't do that stay be loud
be demanding be smart vote for people
who actually represent your values
not grifters not charlatans not people
who are spitting bumper stickers out at
you
even if they also are insulting the
establishment and saying a lot of stuff
you want to hear
and in the meantime like i said get
married have a bunch of kids
buy some guns buy some books buy some
land grow some vegetables turn off the
tv this is the way this is the path
and also don't commit political suicide
with a third party
that's an important part of the path
anyway the third party has been
canceled and that's it
glad we can settle that that's gonna do
it for us today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
democrats celebrate the triumph of
democracy at an inauguration that they
prohibited the people from attending
joe biden rolls back lots of president
trump's accomplishments and the press
couldn't be happier check it out on the
michael knowles show